[Music]
I'm the one
strike and so I went on a pudding strike
oh nice so so folks I don't I don't know
if you heard that or not there's a major
pudding strike going on that we're gonna
talk about but today's guests
they're kind of a big deal both of them
you know we I had a chance to
communicate buck and I were going back
and forth and then we had a chance to uh
be on the show and then uh you know you
guys have you've been around the block
for a while your name is everywhere
everyone knows the Buck Sexton you know
Clay Travis Clay Travis and the Buck
Sexton show whether it's Sports whether
it's politics whether it's boobs whether
it's LeBron there's a lot of different
things going on I'm an expert you're an
expert yeah I like to think and uh Buck
you being a CIA agent this is probably
we just broke a record first time in a
week we've had two Seattle former CI
officers we had a um my man I saw Mike I
did Gutfeld show of them last week did
you Mike and I go way back yes
a interesting fun guy when he comes here
but today's about you guys appreciate
you guys for coming out thank you so
clay uh uh you know for for some of the
folks obviously we got stories to get
into you saw what musk did with BBC
destroyed him and where he started
interviewing the other guy we got stats
that came out from New York City
uh a poll talking about 27 of people
living in New York want to leave New
York I want to get your feedback because
you lived in New York before we got some
other things going on with this guy name
I don't know if you guys are following
this one guy named Joe Biden he's always
saying stuff that we have to cover
France is kind of talking about the fact
that the Europe Europe's got to stop
relying so much on America is that a
good thing is that a bad thing maybe you
were financing everything they're doing
we can talk about that as well
California is on the edge
after Tech layoffs and Studio cutbacks
NPR quits Twitter lots of people were
heartbroken last night when that
announcement was made Popovich once gun
control Cruz hits back NBA NBA blames
economy by the way when I first read
this article what did I ask you Rob I
said what MBA is this and you said it is
the National Basketball Association so I
didn't believe it NBA blames economy for
a hiring freeze and budget cuts Giannis
it kind of opened up recently about
what's going on with him what went on
with him Aaron Rodgers appears to have
endorsed RFK interesting to see that
taking place and then we got Riley
Gaines rips Nike for the partnership
with Dylan Mulvaney and then uh collapse
back at accusations she spread violence
at sfsu event and Joe Rogan has some Bud
Light yesterday on the podcast I don't
know if you guys can oh I didn't even
see that he had some he had somebody
like this around he says listen products
a great product I want to have it it was
so interesting the way he did it but
that's Joe you gotta love Joe for that
so prior to getting into it I know your
story I've known your story four years
but before the audience if you don't
mind taking a moment and sharing your
background that would be great we can
start off with you first so I'm buck uh
and I was born and raised in New York
City I'm now a Floridian though a Miami
and part of the uh Refugee wave from New
York City to Florida as a result of
covid but taking it back a little bit
for anyone in your audience who knows
New York City I went to Regis which if
you're from New York you might know it's
uh the only free private school in the
country that I went to um so everyone's
on a full scholarship then I went to uh
Amherst College came right out of
Amherst went right into the CIA because
911 New Yorker American
uh did CIA from 2005 to 2010 uh deployed
to Iraq twice deployed to Afghanistan
went to some places in sub-Saharan
Africa that I still don't really talk
about and learn some interesting stuff
from that did a year at the NYPD
Intelligence Division and then Glenn
Beck found me out of nowhere
um I was so I was the CIA a guy who had
been in Iraq Afghanistan was working
effectively in like as a consultant for
the NYPD Intelligence Division it's my
hometown and Glenn's person emailed me
out of the blue and was like I heard
about you we should have a meeting I
swear to God and it was actually almost
weirder than the original CIA
recruitment stuff where I was showing up
like abandoned Office Buildings there's
like no one there yeah there is somebody
there you know all the window you know
yeah there's like one guy sitting on a
folding chair that you talked to
um anyway I uh so Glenn brought me in
the business uh at the blaze uh 12. 12
years ago now and uh yeah and then from
there I started doing radio started
filling in for Glenn and then Sean
Hannity then Rush Limbaugh and did some
other things along the way
um you know CNN Fox all that good stuff
and then they paired me up with Clay to
take over as the official Premier Radio
Network's replacement pardon me filling
the slot left vacant by the the greatest
of all time I mean to to follow that guy
I mean they're not going to just put
somebody in that position that doesn't
know what they're doing I remember when
that announcement was made and everybody
said damn that's a pretty big deal so
you know obviously people that follow
the space know how big of a deal that is
Clay how about yourself yeah to speak on
what Buck said I mean I came out of the
world to sports and you usually don't
want to be the guy who follows Bill
Belichick or Nick Saban because usually
the standard is so high and I think
that's why Julie Talbot who's our boss
at Premiere put the two of us in as
opposed to one person so I think it
automatically shifted the dynamic as
opposed to this guy is trying to fill
the shoes as we've said in Buck said I
think pretty well you know we can each
fill one shoe and it's a different show
and I think that was super smart by her
uh but I um look I I was a attorney I
grew up in Nashville went to George
Washington in DC uh went to Vanderbilt
law school graduated moved to the
Caribbean uh and uh I practiced law down
there for a couple of years at the
biggest law firm in the Caribbean
um 13 attorneys by the way in the U.S
Virgin Islands and
um while I was there I had what I would
call a quarter life crisis where where
you look around I know there's probably
a lot of lawyers out there some people
say oh you get your law degree it's
amazing and but every lawyer I've ever
known that I really like has always got
a plan to get out of having to practice
the law really yeah at least in my
experience
I I think because when you're in law
school and when you're working up
towards that what I always say is law
school you get to debate big important
issues uh you get to study the most
seminal cases that have ever existed in
the legal process and then your first
year your 25 or 26 years old and you sit
in front of a computer and you do Doc
review and so it is not this A Few Good
Men A Time to Kill caliber experience
and I think a lot of young lawyers sort
of have that gilded this is going to be
amazing and you make a decent living but
it's an awful job especially as a young
lawyer in my experience and I and I even
even I always say and this is my advice
to anybody out there who's young and
think about it if you you don't want
your boss's boss's job you should find
something new to do don't just look
directly above you look at the person
who's your boss's boss if you see what
they do and you're like ah this doesn't
really have that much appeal to me
there's nothing wrong with doing a job
you don't love everybody has to do it
but if you aspire to truly love what you
do then if you don't want to do what
your boss's boss does that's the next 10
15 years so you don't want to own a law
firm you don't have to run a law firm I
didn't want to run off
um and uh and so I practiced the law for
a few years started writing online I
worked and I was in the World of Sports
so uh probably the reason why I ended up
writing online is speaking to being a
young lawyer and everybody I knew
graduated with was a young lawyer you're
hoping to find 10 or 15 minutes of
entertainment on the internet during
your day you're not happy you want to go
click and go read this article or
whatever so I started writing hopefully
funny amusing humorous uh articles
online about Southeastern Conference
football I was a monster still am
College football fan football fan in
general and that led to I did that for
years eventually he's making a hundred
dollars a week at CBS Sports line if you
remember that website back in the day
CBS Sportsline yeah did you what year
was that when you were there I started
writing there in o5 did you work with
Peter Madden uh I know that name yes
very interesting but so they were based
here yeah they're right here down the
street yeah down the street uh they paid
me a hundred dollars a week to write
down
uh 100 a week so after years I had made
five thousand dollars at that point uh a
week uh sorry a year and I was still
practicing law full-time that eventually
led to uh they got me up to I think to
35 or 40K and I thought I was I was like
this is amazing then I went to Deadspin
if you guys remember dead spin back in
its Heyday
um this is kind of early web you know I
would say almost 1.0 I had good timing
you know the blogosphere was just kind
of taken off
um and then I was at Fan house I got
fired they shut down the entire if you
guys remember the fan House business
model they shut down everything
everybody got fired whole place and I
started a website called the out kick in
2011 and I sold that to Fox two years
ago and so slowly I moved from hey let's
rank the top five quarterbacks I did
National Sports Talk Radio I did local
Sports Talk Radio and then
um when covet happened
March April May June our audience
skyrocketed uh and it was not Sports and
so our boss Julie Talbot when Rush
passed came and said hey the data
reflects people just want to hear your
opinion uh not just about sports how was
that how was that uh into to to to hear
that people want to hear your opinion on
politics Not Just Sports was that a easy
transition for you well it was I loved
the show that I did yeah um and it was
early morning Fox Sports Radio I was on
six to nine a.m Eastern
um and I I think this is where having
the kids you start a pivot and think not
only about yourself but about the larger
world and I love talking about who's
going to win the Super bowl or who's
going to win the NBA play but it doesn't
matter right it's all 100 entertainment
and so whether schools are open during
covid or frankly whether kids can go
play high school sports because you guys
probably know and I know Buck does too I
got lots of people I know who wouldn't
have had success in life if they hadn't
gotten to play on the right high school
team or have the right coach especially
boys and so I I was just so fired up
about finding ways to play and sports
had become more and more unfortunately
intertwined with politics I would say
really kind of taken off with the Colin
Kaepernick protest and that whole world
it was like in many ways you were
talking about politics when you tried to
talk about sports and so uh I remember
Julie saying and this is true we're very
fortunate We have basically the biggest
Radio Show in the country she said look
you could have the best and biggest
Sports Talk Show that exists in the
country and I think you're on track to
be able to do that it would still be a
pinprick of the influence that the
audience that you're going to be able to
talk to uh in Russia's time slot would
be able to influence the first time I
filled in for Rush was I think so I was
a guest host for him for years just to
Clay's Point
um I think it was 2014 or 2015 so it was
a ways back I made this sort of
proclamation I'm like I'm going to
respond anyone who wants to email me you
know I'm going to respond you know
because I was used to doing I started
doing Digital radio before I was on
terrestrial radio on the weekends yeah I
had a stream on the blaze I was super
early in the sort of podcast stream
space relatively speaking and then
transitioned to terrestrial which is
kind of not the way people usually do it
but I was used to I told clay this
because I also I was a writer for
theblaze.com and I was doing Blaze TV
and Blaze radio so I was doing all three
of these at the time this is when I got
my start and I could actually see did
you have a chart bead of one of those
things oh where you could actually say
yeah I could see doing my show like
there'd be nine people listening this is
when I first started and then I talked
about something like a couple drop off
and I'm like oh man I just lost 30 of my
audience or like 20 of my audience or
whatever so it would like kind of
freaked me out a little bit
um but you know I I always found that uh
it was it was interesting to see that
that radio seemed to bring in the people
who
um just had the most content all the
time like that was my impression coming
in like people had the most to share
because you know TV you have people who
are amazing and people who you know are
relying what stops you more which audio
stops you more you know how you know the
other day I'm at any I'm at a church
and this guy comes up and he says you're
the tick tock guy I'm like dude I'm not
a tick tock that's awesome bro I'm not a
tick tock I would say this one guy at
UFC is like you're you're the Jeweler
that's right you're a jewelry guy you're
like yeah oh I got one watch video just
what the thing I forgot to say was to
play I said I would respond I spent like
six hours responding to emails from
doing Russia's show once I've never seen
anything like it before in my life in
terms of the platform and the connection
what was the number 20 to 30 million I
would hear right what was it that was
the reach on a monthly basis
what we've seen too since then and yeah
the reach is still amazing I think we
have 500 affiliate stations Nationwide
uh roughly but also now we've layered on
top of that the podcast which is and
buck and I are the buck likes to make
fun of it he's three years younger than
me which totally old man look at all the
gray in that beer I'm the last year of
Gen X and he's one of the first years
the Millennials so that's why I'm so
much more likable
um
the uh but you know then you layer on
top of it tens of millions of downloads
and what we found I'm sure you have seen
it too it's funny you say oh you're the
tick tock guy there was this initial
fear in radio that you would cannibalize
your audience and what the data actually
reflects is people come now from so many
different directions so you're asking a
really interesting question where like
what do people recognize because I did
four years of sports gambling daily on
FS1 so like when I came in when I'm
applying to Fort Lauderdale yesterday uh
or thought I was before the flood
um I uh 22 inches of rain by the way but
go ahead it's unbelievable I go through
and the guy checking my ID is like man
who you got tonight in the NBA playoffs
right and then so I you know give him
picks and I went one-on-one so whatever
but uh I felt bad he was like if you go
into I'm gonna blow you up on Twitter I
was like I know buddy uh trust me and
then uh get to the airplane and people
are like man can you believe what uh
macron said about uh you know I'm
sitting waiting to get uh get on the
flight somebody wants to talk about
macron so it's kind of i i people come
from different directions with their own
perspectives and that was always kind of
my goal I wanted them to want to talk
about Game of Thrones or uh you know
what's going on in politics or you know
whatever would be on the front page of
the newspaper top of mind so you you
asked a really interesting question
because it's something that I learned
from from years of seeing it play out
not just with me but with other hosts
who are friends the people who know you
from TV tend to recognize you the people
who know you from Radio know you they
will hug you they will come up to you
and they'll talk about you know your dog
or they'll come up and they just because
they spend so much time now granted I
haven't hosted a show on Fox so it's
different from people just from but I
mean if they see you on TV doing
appearances they're like oh I like your
content if they're spending two maybe
three hours a day with you five days a
week I mean we were I spend more time
talking to Clay than anybody in his
family with a possible exception of his
wife right imagine the I definitely talk
more to you than 15 hours I mean 15
hours to your wife I mean no it's kind
of yeah now that I think it will
recognize you from TV do you spend a lot
of time at senior homes is that is that
kind of what you do is that what's going
on I mean that's a good shot but I'll
tell you this I've got I mentioned I had
three boys I took a picture of your 1
million YouTube thing in the lobby yeah
because all my boys watches YouTube yeah
they watch sports live sports with me
and then every thing else they do
YouTube so when I show them that one
million I got to meet Mr Beast a couple
years ago he's like 100 so he's a small
small YouTube channel no big deal but my
kids I mean I would imagine it was like
getting to meet Elvis in 1960 you know
to them I think Pat brings I think he
was kind of joking with you about has
your audience at a senior community but
the landscape has changed right TV yeah
cable news older audience radio my first
job out of college was in radio this is
2002 2003 Clear Channel yep it was the
King of the Hill right there Rob worked
in radio for I don't know forever I
think he even had a radio show at one
point yeah Hugh Hewitt and those guys
like 15 13 forever ago but now the
landscape is YouTube podcasts and things
have changed right oh yeah what have you
seen the biggest difference Ben so the
demos are obviously different from
podcast YouTube and you know I would say
tick tock which is kind of replace
Snapchat in there you know in this
hierarchy or in this separation
right right that's like the youngest
demo for content and then right above
that probably you have YouTube and then
above that you have uh podcasting and
then above that you have cable news in
terms of you know age stratification and
then you know at the very top of it I
would say terrestrial radio tends to be
an older more established newspapers
above that I still get a journal so the
only two people I know on the planet who
get the old school paper or paper uh
Wall Street Journal are my dad and Clay
he's got the ninja moves with the actual
physical paper but no we we approach it
I mean one thing that I was told because
so you know Glenn uh started started the
blaze when he left Fox and he'd add that
remember that when he used to do
four e's and the fox he's to crush it by
the way that show was people wouldn't
miss it at night so I was at the
Intelligence Division the NYPD and I
just remember all we had all these
screens up that you know some of it is
like trying to stop terrorism but also
then there were TVs then there were TVs
of you know the news and it would all
turn to Glenn at fi at five o'clock uh
you know every day and um but one thing
that that he recognized very early on I
actually don't think he gets enough
credit for this in the conservative
space is he was like we just need to be
present with good content everywhere so
he was in a podcasting streaming I
remember Roku I didn't know what a Roku
was I went to work at the Blaze and they
had Roku for TV so you know in the early
days of that you could see that there
were going to be a lot more ways to be
able to consume content but the good
news is that it also means the the
audience is a lot bigger but then again
everybody has a pot like people come up
to me now they're like hey I want to
start a podcast I'm like have you have
you ever done a podcast you know like
I'm like I mean that's great like go for
it but you know it feels like these days
a lot of people are are uh everyone
wants to be an influencer that's the
term an influencer well I'll I'll build
on uh you mentioned somebody came up and
said you're a tick tock guy
um so you guys I don't know if you've
seen this clip if you haven't you should
should watch it like four years ago I
went on CNN and said I only believed in
two things completely the first
amendment in boobs right live on the air
they banned me I'm not allowed on CNN
now because you said boobs because I
said boobs straight up it was my friend
who banned him by the way but I didn't
know him at the time so otherwise I
would have stepped in just because you
said the word the contested
it was the number one trending topic in
America uh she wanted me to apologize I
didn't do it the reason why I bring it
up is that was like four or five years
ago my uh oldest son
last year
on the screen yeah there we go that's it
oh man
can we play that amendment absolutist I
believe in only two things completely
the First Amendment and boobs and so
once they made the decision that they
were not did you just say wow
related commentary hold on hold on I
just want to make sure I heard you
correctly as a woman anchoring the show
did you say what did you say you believe
in the First Amendment ends bwbs
you can't even say boobs two things that
have only never let me down in this
entire country
first amendment absolutist I believe so
you got canceled because of that oh they
tried I mean legitimately they tried to
get me fired off my radio show I mean I
owned out kicks so I mean that's one of
the benefits I think of owning your own
methods of distribution and I would say
to anybody who wants to get involved in
media
um one of the most important things is
you have to control I believe your
ability to make money in some way
because there's so much pressure out
there on media entities that as soon as
you get a little bit outside of the
acceptable bounds of discourse uh but
that clip that you guys watched I think
that was 2017-ish 18 whatever it was it
suddenly went viral on Tick Tock and so
every kid in my kids school very
interested never knew it existed got it
right because they're like eight or nine
years old when that happens yeah
suddenly every one of them had seen it
millions of people it was all positive
the kids loved it but that was an
audience that had never seen me I I
first saw your content on Tick Tock by
the way so yeah
so I mean I know we go from the podcast
obviously but that's also how I mean I
know you guys had Tate on yeah and you
know he's now home uh home confinement
right in Romania I've been reaching out
we've been reaching out to his team for
a couple of weeks right before the
arrest happened because we weren't we
want to have him on it's funny because I
was like it's like look like this guy
says really interesting stuff I know
he's controversial and all that stuff
and obviously he's facing his charges
now but clay and I talked about it we
hadn't you know brought it up before I
looked at him I'm like like I see this
guy on Tick Tock I think we should have
him on the show I think it's really
interesting some of the stuff that he's
saying and he's like he's like he's my
son's favorite my two oldest boys every
now and then I'll go and I'll say like
hey because I mentioned they're on
YouTube they're on wait hold your boys
by the way uh 15 12 and eight okay
oh yeah the two oldest I said hey if I
could have anybody on the radio show
who would you like me to have on and
they both instantaneously said Andrew
Tate and then Buck brought him up like
the next you know two or three days
later happenstance yeah but I think it
speaks to there's a lot of boys out
there and we've talked about this on our
show that feel lost in this sort of
toxic masculinity era and so they're
looking for that's why I mentioned
coaches earlier but that masculine
influence who can tell teach them how to
be men and I feel like his individual
like hey just go do more push-ups uh and
stop being a [__] like that actually
connects a lot you guys remember with 13
14 15 year old boys yeah there's no
question about it I asked the question
when I said like who's the audience when
people come in they'll talk to me I'll
say so how do you know about us and what
we do oh I watch Valium all the time I
said do you watch the podcast or just by
timing which podcast okay great so
you're more to Value team an audience
how about yourself you know I I watch
the podcast and I listen you know
through Spotify okay so Spotify
interesting audience what do you do for
I I want to know what the background of
these guys are yeah Tick Tock if I go to
school with my kids their kids well
their friends will stop by because
they're Tick Tock audience right snap
audience I can't really find a Snapchat
audience there's Instagram there's
YouTube there's Spotify there's you know
Tick Tock but it's different if I go on
Fox and I see who stops me I'm on a Dan
bongino show and next thing you know the
following day hey you know I saw
yesterday on the damn bongino show it's
okay that makes sense older crowd yeah
it's a very different crowd but the the
thing when you're
starting out I think is you gotta when
you're newer not you guys you guys you
guys are at this point your vets you're
running the show with the biggest
eyeballs you took a spot that everybody
want everybody was fighting for that
spot I remember the whole talk was this
guy's gonna get it is he gonna get it is
that going to get it no way thank God
that's insane right everybody was
talking about that slot but uh you when
you start out it's important to have a
very Niche audience to start off with
and then gradually as you go wider and
you talk other opinions people say damn
you actually can talk about that stuff
can we hear more things like that kind
of like what you were talking about
earlier the thing about radio I said
like the people come up yeah and I
literally mean that like if someone
comes up and they're like [__] and they
hug me and I don't know them they listen
to me on radio and some of the listing
for 12 years crazy I mean there's some
people there have been I I know of a a
couple that's married because they both
listen to my show and through hashtags
they found each other I swear to God
guys in the military found each other
Founders as well just just because
the most impressive thing for some of
the people that listen from Tick Tock is
when you said you transitioned that's
becoming very common nowadays to
transition and it's it's impressive that
maybe you started that some years ago
years ago I like to think that I'm a guy
who adapts very quickly you know that's
part of the trading part of the CIA
training and plus we had you know
understanding of how to how to shape my
name is Buck Sexton and I've
transitioned from from CIA to Media
they're just gonna clip that on yeah
but just real quick are you talking
about all these platforms it also is
it's a business strategy but it's also a
survival mechanism and we saw this
particularly during covet I mean
survival you know within the within the
business
um because now everyone really
understands what some of us have been
shouting about for a long time we've
both dealt with this a bit I mean you
showed clay trying to cancel I've been
I've been throttled suspended kicked off
account shut down and it was all really
over covet stuff so now people
understand that you got to be on you
know on YouTube tube on rumble on
Spotify all these different places
because if you go all in on one place
they will turn the lights off on you for
political reasons for nonsense reasons
right not for anything that anybody so
that's why I think also being
multi-platform is is kind of a necessity
now uh for for almost everybody who's in
the business more than being a
multi-platform individual yourself is
who's running those different platforms
like one of the best things that
happened is Spotify backed up Rogan okay
muskbot Twitter yep and Rumble is
growing those three things are very very
good for Content creators because just
two three years ago one person in
Silicon Valley canceled you 99 other
people canceled you as well similar to
what happened a couple guys that we both
know about all right let's go into some
stories here you're from New York okay
article came out yesterday from uh New
York uh post nearly a third of New
Yorkers want to move out this is after
all the 330 000 you know the numbers
that we've all read about and how many
people left nearly a third of New
Yorkers want to move out fed up with
crime housing costs poor schools and
more if you look at the bottom with
stats
New Yorkers are so worried about crime
Sky High housing costs and struggling
schools 27 percent of State residents
said they want to move away in the next
five years of survey survey revealed a
stunning 30 respondent who also cited
inept political leadership and soaring
taxes as reasons for wanting to flee
said they already longed to live
somewhere else according to Siena
College Research Institute quality of
life poll nearly a third 31 plan to
leave the Empire State when they retire
while even more said they believe it's
not safe for kids Angela Gutierrez 38 of
East Harlem is one of the New Yorkers
who will soon ditch the state the more
and more you looked at the stats I mean
this was a place that everybody wanted
to be at bottom stats I'll read to you
and I'll turn it over to you guys 67 of
residents in New York wasn't affordable
while only 30 said it was 49 of
respondents at New York uh fair or poor
when asked if it's a place where they
feel safe from Prime only 51 gave an
answer of good or excellent crime surged
during the pandemic sixty percent of New
York is not a good place to retire while
38 said it was 57 said the political
system doesn't work I mean I can go on
and on and on and on and on what do you
think is really happening in New York
because when I talk to New Yorkers
they'll say things like this they'll say
no one's going to leave New York no
matter what they say no one's leaving
New York this is the place to be this is
the mecca this is where everybody comes
to what's really going on in New York
people who say that are unfortunately
delusional so I'm born and raised in New
York City
um both my parents were born in New York
City three of my four Grandparents were
born in New York city so we go back
quite a ways in in NYC I grew up in a
New York just for the the purpose of the
audience to understand what has happened
here because New York went through an
incredible really almost miraculous fix
and now has been ruined again
effectively or is in the process I
should say being ruined so when I grew
up in New York City which is early like
let's say early 90s 19 90 New York had
over 2200 murders okay people go back
and they always they say there's no way
you can check that statistic it was 22
something uh over 2 000 murders which
when you think about what we're looking
at now in different cities I mean New
York got went from 2200 murders Giuliani
comes in there's this whole change in
the approach to to crime and criminal
justice and everything by the time I'm
graduating high school New York is now
looking at can we get below 300 murders
think about that from 2200 people gunned
down to in a decade or so you're like
can we get it to like 2 250 275. so that
happened which was phenomenal in New
York I do think obviously 911 but
actually the response from the city to
911 and the it was incredible how fast
the bounce back was from the biggest
attack on our country since Pearl Harbor
and obviously it's what led me to the
CIA and trying to I literally got out of
college and I was like I want to help
find Bin Laden and kill that SOB like
that was my mission in life I went to
work for CTC in the CIA so New York was
this amazing place it got super safe
clay always says in the show and it's
totally true that you want to be able to
live in a place where your wife can go
jogging at night and you don't even
think twice about it and I'm telling you
New York in the 2000s from let's say
2000 to 2010 2011 before de Blasio 100
the case so then you get de Blasio who
comes in the problem is New York City
had been so safe so wealthy and was the
mecca that those people talk about that
it seemed like it was you know an
Unsinkable Battleship of of Awesomeness
right it's just oh okay we can have we
can raise taxes we can start to do
things that are we can go a little more
lacks on crime let's get rid of stop and
frizz let's change some of these
policies we've made it safe we don't
need to keep doing these things anymore
and it started to deteriorate what they
don't realize is that there's a momentum
to these things not only did you have de
Blasio at the top pushing effectively
socialist policies in New York but then
you also bring in and I had one of my
best friends in the world was in the
district attorney's office for like over
a decade so I was always talking to him
about this and I worked the NYPD you
start seating they talk about the Soros
back prosecutors yeah you also get
leftist radicals not only in these
different activist groups but also they
start working for city government
themselves they start coming in they
start pushing this ideology more and
then as the city began to deteriorate
you could see that they were still
hoping well you have to be here that's
the thing about New York it was kind of
like Hollywood and la and Silicon Valley
right into places where they got you
there's almost a monopoly on the
industry well coven covet comes along so
even though there are people like this
is getting it's getting dirty it's
getting unsafe it's way too expensive
they got rid of the salt deduction covet
comes along and now you realize you're
actually ruled over by totalitarian
morons who don't care if they create
misery and economic destruction because
they think that this is what social
justice looks like New York is going to
take at least a decade if not decades to
recover to what it was based on the
damage that was done uh particularly I'd
say in the last 10 years in the city but
kova just sent it all into overdrive so
that's that's how it all broke down I
felt fortunate because I lived in
Nashville just south of town and it was
like covet didn't even exist you know I
mean uh I spent I came down here uh my
kids were out of school you know March
April May
um and I came down to Florida and we
spent May because I was like how often
are the kids going to be out for the
whole time we'll just spend a month at
the beach but I think I I went up to
visit where Buck lived
and New York is great not because for
most people where they live in New York
City but because when you leave your
apartment you can experience the city
and what covet did was take away the
experience and a lot of people were like
this is kind of a shitty place to live
if you don't have the larger experience
of the city and then on top of what Buck
said I think a lot of people then made
choices that they never would have if
covet didn't happen and they said okay
I'm gonna try to do my job and I'm gonna
go outside of the city and what they
found out was I can be just as efficient
outside of the city as I would be
otherwise because you would have never
suddenly if you got a successful
business you never would have made the
choices to try things that you had to do
during covid but when you did I think
what happened and I've been on this and
for a while covid made red redder and
blue Bluer and it accelerated what I
think has become very much of a national
divorce and I'll be honest with you
if I had been living in New York City or
L.A when I when I started out kick to
Bucks Point everybody said you can't run
a media business from Nashville you're
going to have to move at some point to
New York or La uh I think that's totally
false I think there are a lot of
different cities now where there's a lot
of talent in Miami South Florida is one
Nashville is one where I live Austin
Texas is one
um and people realize that they could be
based anywhere and so the Allure of New
York City when your kids are having to
wear masks for years when your kids are
having to live remotely when you're
cramped in a tiny little apartment you
can barely get outside to walk a dog and
you can't take your kids to a park
suddenly wasn't there and I think it's
going to take a while because now people
have experienced other things Buck you
know you know this like something I'm
one of these people yeah I'm here wait a
minute I can a a million dollar place in
New York I get you know 700 square feet
on the 28th floor of a building or I can
be in Boise Idaho and I can have a
Monster House right and I think it
caused people too it's in Boise oh yeah
cause people to experience new things
and uh and I so I think the result is
red red or blue Bluer and I think we're
just starting to experience that
conflict of what that's going to create
I also think that during covid and this
was a big part of why I decided to move
and leave and I do thank Governor Ron
DeSantis for what he did during the
pandemic I was one of those people I
mean I was actually the one who tweeted
uh during the pandemic early on that
leaving New York City for Florida was
the closest thing you could experience
as an American to leaving East Germany
for West Germany in the 1960s I mean you
went from you know being at LaGuardia
Airport where there were actual National
Guard soldiers like what are they
they're going to shoot the virus and the
whole thing was insane they're they're
taking down information for test and
Trace the dumbest program in the history
of the Universe I remember arguing with
doctors about this it was a guy's test
and trace this has never worked anywhere
this is insane and they'd say it works
for s TDS
well yeah because when you ask you know
you would think that's a little bit
easier to figure out right but there was
a mentality there was a psychosis that
took over the leadership class there you
came down to Florida and people were
splashing around in the ocean or going
to restaurants they're living their
lives I'm like what the hell is going on
here and then I realized oh
the the 90 of New York City residents
who voted or it's like 80 actually but
90 of Manhattan is Democrat 80 percent
of the city is Democrat they're part of
the apparatus now they're okay with this
like they're they've been so brainwashed
that I I actually reached the point
where I was no longer just angry at at
the time the mayor of New York Bill de
Blasio I was angry at the people who
were shouting at everybody to wear masks
outside because what was wrong with them
like what had happened to them fellow
New Yorkers were supposed to have this
like tough we don't take any Guff you
know any BS from anybody attitude or
whatever no we turned into a bunch of
triple masking you know wimps who were
begging for the government to protect
them and do all the it was crazy and so
I'm I'm angry about what was done to the
city and I'm actually still very angry
at the people who were in charge uh
across the board what a point to to say
that you know New Yorkers are known to
not back down and now you're just
staring whatever they're telling them
impressive Adam Progressive research
over there yeah well look I think I
think um Clay is absolutely right sort
of during covet the red got redder the
blue gut Bluer born and raised in Miami
so welcome to Miami officially awesome
thank you um you know I love New York
City I'm actually going this weekend and
I mean I would never move there yeah but
spend a week or two there hanging around
in the city
still my favorite City I love it just it
everything that kind of comes with the
city the price attached to living in New
York City is kind of insane you said you
can get a million dollar house in Boise
for you get a million dollar shoe box in
New York City
um you know I actually went during Cova
this would have been when we were in
Boca sort of been 2021 I do a lot of man
on the street interviews and I went
around and I started interviewing
everybody in New York basically this was
when 30 billion dollars of tax revenue
left the city yeah and I went just
talking to average people like so did
you stay in New York why'd you leave New
York what would you consider leaving New
York you know and you get a wide variety
of answers but you know the the common
themes were taxes are insane right the
cost of living is insane just basically
the prices are insane and it's one guy
was like listen maybe just people aren't
tough enough to stick it out in New York
you know the old Frank Sinatra if you
can make it here you can make it
anywhere but I think you know I've seen
so many people because because I used to
work in Nightlife and every base
basically winter Christmas New Year's
like the New Yorkers would come and Us
South Beach promoters were like all
right let's charge these mother suckers
double and I would see this love affair
with Miami in South Florida from all the
New Yorkers and we would see them kind
of tiptoe each year like all right yeah
one week this year one month and then
I'll be like one of these guys gonna
freaking wake up and realize you could
just move here yeah and I think covet
basically was the impetus for them to
get the hell out of here what you hit on
and buck and I have talked about this
it's not just people leaving it's the
people that have the most resources that
are legal and yeah you know the
difference between yeah 13 and 14 tax in
California and in New York and where you
guys are in Florida where Buck is now
and where I am in Tennessee we have no
state income tax same thing in Texas
let's just use those three as an example
if you make a million dollars a year
that's 130 or a hundred and forty
thousand dollars extra in your pocket
that's a million imagine if you make 10
million or a hundred million I don't
understand I mean just be quite honest I
don't understand why anybody who is
wealthy and I mean supremely wealthy
would ever make their residence in New
York or LA and I think covid some of
those guys were like well I've got so
much money at stake I've got a hedge
fund I got private Equity I've got to be
based here suddenly when covet happened
those guys took chances in terms of
where they lived that they never would
have otherwise and their revenue didn't
change and then they're looking at it
now and they're like why would I ever
give a government 14 for the privilege
of living you know that's why your Nicks
suck man everyone looks at the uh uh you
know well contracts going on over there
it's like why the hell would I move to
New York I grew up watching the Knicks
and it's funny because Ewing Larry
Johnson John Starks those are your games
Squad are you kidding me the oak tree I
remember all of my brother had an
Anthony Mason Jersey because his name is
Mason so it said Mason on the back like
we we love the Knicks growing up
um I have since stopped watching both
the NBA and the NFL for reasons that I
don't think are what do you mean you
just don't watch anymore I will not
watch no straight up for politics yeah I
won't do it because everything that
happened with Colin Kaepernick and the
bubble and the social justice stuff
you're just not into it won't do it
don't watch and you were a lifelong
Sports guy I mean I grew up yeah I grew
up actually playing a little bit I
wasn't very good or anything but I grew
up playing because you just couldn't get
that helmet on your on your head bro
what's funny you say that because I
avoided helmet Sports specifically
because I didn't like even this is going
to give me a headache if I keep it on
because my head's too big
um but yeah so I stopped watching sports
I did grow up though uh you know going
to games Yankee Stadium but I mean
Yankee Stadium just to give you showed
that thing it was like my dad would have
a talk to me like I remember when I when
I was in Afghanistan like before we
would we would go out you know in the
city and you get together and get
together with our guys these GRS guys
who are all you know they're they're
seals Special Forces Delta guys and
they're trying to if you've seen 13
hours right of course those guys so I
was if you see that movie I was one of
the guys that they're sort of with you
know they're the shooters and I'm there
to you know have the meeting or talk to
people or whatever but we'd have this
conversation about like what are we
going to run up against here like what
do we think the chances of IDs or
whatever
it kind of reminded me when I was a
little kid my dad was like we're going
to Yankee Stadium it was everyone in New
York was like you know it's really
dangerous around there like we're not
gonna go walking around there and that
was just considered you didn't go into
Central Park at night if you went into
Central Park at night growing up in New
York City and you got robbed it was on
you it was like what are you doing in
the park this is the nicest park in the
richest part of the whole city but like
if you win it at night you got robbed so
those are those are sort of the the
changes that I think happened
psychologically in New York but also
like you can get you know I was telling
him this the other day too you can find
what you want everywhere in the country
now in a way you couldn't before so in a
lot of the big like New York Chicago La
they had just better food than other
places I know people argue about this
but they're wrong like in the 90s you
know a good restaurant in Nashville no
offense was not a good restaurant in New
York City now it is same level same
quality of food you can buy anything
anywhere I made a joke on Twitter you
could go on Amazon now and buy a tank I
don't know if you still can but it used
to be you're in New York is that the
best food the best shopping and all all
the job opportunities you needed if
you're a single guy the biggest dating
pool in the whole country concentrated
in one place a lot of that stuff now
doesn't really matter don't you think
there's a metaphor with kind of what
you're saying about these cities with
exactly what we were talking about with
the podcasts and basically you don't
need to be in these mainstream Legacy
Media companies you can just kind of
have your own YouTube channel or your
own podcasting Channel versus you don't
need to be in these major cities anymore
you can just kind of do it from anywhere
yeah I mean building on what Buck said I
remember going to New York City as a kid
the bookstores like for people out there
who are around my age I'm 44. you would
go if you grew up where I did in in
Goodlettsville Tennessee which is not
necessarily the fancy area of Nashville
you went to Walden books right in your
mall and Walden books might have I don't
know 15 000 book or titles or something
in it and you would go if you're trying
to read something and I was a huge
reader you would go there and you would
hope that they might have a book that
you wanted to read right clay wins a
civil war camp by the way his true story
true story legit Civil War sleep away
camp
um but uh but the uh but then I remember
coming to New York City and being like
Oh my God Barnes and Noble like my thing
that I was most impressed by New York
City wasn't the you know huge buildings
it was all of the bookstores that were
everywhere and being able to find books
you couldn't get anywhere now you go on
Amazon and get any book delivered to
your house in 12 hours I mean I moved to
Miami's what I don't know six months ago
now something like that I haven't been
shopping once everything just gets
delivered right and so that's true now
all over the country so it's kind of the
the amazoning or amazonification of the
country has also changed I think one of
the big advantages of being in a city
you know for people who used to live out
in like more rural areas even some of
the suburbs it's like oh like God you
know if you want to get something you
had to get in a car for 40 minutes right
now everything gets delivered to your
front door so it changes and even
pushing the remote concept backfired on
a lot of these cities when New York City
or San Francisco oh everybody can work
from home for the rest of their lives oh
really no problem I will work from home
in Texas
I will work from home from Florida yeah
or Tennessee and I won't pay the taxes
not a problem we support your remote now
they're [__] bricks say no no that
remote work was just a idea we got to
get back to the office this is not
working out you know commercial real
estate taking hit these Class A
buildings are taking a hit so a lot of
these ideas that they drove is exactly
what backfired on them well it's built
building on Buck making fun of me for
reading old school newspapers I was on
the airplane yesterday reading my old
school newspaper by the way almost the
only person now on on the airplane who
actually carries newspapers and to what
you're saying Facebook has fired I think
30 percent of their Workforce and I know
Elon Musk has wiped out 80 percent of
Twitter's Workforce but they said many
of the top managers at Facebook now some
of the guys are living in Europe uh some
of the guys like they aren't even top
level employees at Facebook are
traveling sometimes back to Silicon
Valley but they're actually based in
Europe yeah so I think to your point the
child challenge that a lot of these
companies are having is one we're
finding out that they can do their work
with a fraction of the people right I
mean Twitter is running basically as
effectively it appears to me on 1500
employees as it was eight thousand and I
think Elon Musk has given a lot of these
big tech companies knowledge of just how
many people they employ that that they
don't need and just one more thing on
the looking at the crime statistics I
mean people always Focus immediately on
on homicides for obvious reasons right
what's the most serious crime and also
it's very hard for that to me messed
with as a stat right people tend to know
when there's a body when someone's been
killed and that's not something that a
city can hide quality of life stuff
though I mean this is what you're really
seeing in San Francisco although there's
violent crime there too that we've seen
recently quality of life crimes in
pretty much every major city which are
all under Democrat control not to make
it too political but it is political
they're they're completely through the
roof meaning just the day-to-day stuff
you know people seeing
um you know open air drug usage age and
the effective or actual
decriminalization of drugs
um you know needles on the streets all
that kind of stuff that makes people not
want to go into the downtown also right
so there's there's a Snowball Effect
here things just kind of keep getting
bigger because the remote work is easier
you can go to a low tax place and also I
mean do you want to go into downtown San
Francisco these days do you want to go
into you know even like Times Square in
New York has gotten a lot sketchier in
the last few years you would think that
but they voted uh the same type of Mayor
in Chicago San Francisco is not changing
they voted a Democratic governor
although she almost lost to uh the other
guy who was creating a lot of momentum
he what's his name the New York Governor
that was running up against uh what was
his name
zeldon made a name for himself they
thought hey you're going to run for
president think about this Lee zeldin
wins
Brad gets fired Trump doesn't get
indicted so that decision by those
Democrats in New York not to go along
with Lee zeldin may change the history
of the country in a pretty profound way
as this legal issue for film plays out
and also think about how much harder we
talked about this on the show those
cities and those States
only have themselves to blame and I
think Buck's analogy on New York City is
a great one from 2200 down to 300 or 250
or whatever the murder rate went to it's
because people in New York City got so
fed up they said okay bring in Rue
Giuliani wall elect a republican we're
gonna have to shake up what we're doing
they're so committed the left Wingers
are that they just elected this guy
Brandon Johnson in Chicago for an
example he and and we've talked about
those on the show got the support
overwhelmingly from the highest crime
areas and he's basically a defund the
police guy so one of the challenges I
think that's going to be in play here is
a lot of sane people have bailed and
they're just not voting there to the
point on Lee zeldin how many probably
several hundred thousand would be red
voters have just said I'm done with New
York that's how we made Florida redder
top DeSantis won by 19 points how much
more challenging is it going to be for
that pivot to occur because they're
losing some of the middle of the road
sane voters that would otherwise have
allowed moderates to win so let me ask
you this in New York we beat up New York
plenty let's go to the next topic but
it's within this topic so you know every
election season different topics matter
uh midterms everybody talk about Roe v
Wade bad timing it's McConnell's fault
he did it intentionally to her from to
show that hey by getting an endorsement
for Maga no longer means as much as it
did before we got to go a different way
we got to get a rhino candidate okay
great you go Trump Ran hey it's got to
be a border it's going to make America
great again we got to pay attention to
the border China tariffs you know
everybody runs on something that's
timely that people are interested in if
you guys were hired to be the campaign
managers or strategists behind closed
doors for DeSantis or Trump what would
be the top three you know items you
would be driving that the voters right
now are most concerned about
um he wrote a book on this so he's going
to happen
so I'll just I'll do an appetizer and he
can do the entree on this one um I I
think the the border is an enormously
important issue all these things have to
be message the right way and people have
to really understand why it matters as
well as just the constant you know
bringing this up and part of the
national conversation I mean I think the
the border the economy is always always
top three so what could be done for the
economy that we better that would be
better than what we've seen
um and I really also think as Ukraine is
heating up people that come forward and
explain how we spent 20 years fighting
in Wars I was as a civilian CI analyst
not a door kicker but I was in a couple
of those War zones saw what was going on
personally the fact that it feels like
we've almost forgotten the lessons of
what are we doing here and what is the
strategy this quickly with this Ukraine
Mission creep it is a hundred percent
Mission creep that we have you know it's
always incremental so it feels like oh
but we're not you know we don't have you
well actually we do have U.S troops
there as they've now come out what do
you mean by Mission creep that it's just
going to incrementally get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger of a thing
exactly so it's not like we're going to
be pulling out anytime soon like an
Afghanistan situation we're gonna be
doubling down we are going to be
supporting the ukrainians against the
Russians for years this war will go on
for years and anybody who doubts that
should remember that the the war has
been going on already since 2014 when
they initially invaded the donbass and
then had the phony referendum in Crimea
I mean it was a referendum but it was at
gunpoint whatever this has already been
building for a long time this issue is
much more important to the Russians than
it is to us they will go to the mat on
this one there is no oh Putin's under
too much pressure the guy who takes over
after Putin he's not going to want to
give up Ukraine either whoever that
would be so somebody who can say I'm
going to keep us out of a war we're only
going to war if someone's starting a war
with us I think that would be very
powerful I think that's why Trump by the
way in his recent Tucker interview Focus
so much on that foreign policy piece
secure the Border
um oh and then I know you said three I'm
sorry economy we could all agree and the
other one be crime crime is huge
Republicans are up 10 up 12 up 15
depending on the poll you see against
Democrats in crime because they've
basically decided to legalize crime as
part of a social justice initiatives and
all kinds of crazy left-wing abolish the
police ideology so that's what we got so
you mentioned DeSantis and Trump let me
actually start with Biden
um if Trump is the nominee
Joe by my concern is and I think it's
true Joe Biden's entire record won't
matter because his entire campaign is
going to be I'm not Trump
and most of the time elections are
referendums on the incumbent my concern
is Trump versus Biden 24 the entire
story is going to be Biden saying I'm
not Trump and those Suburban
college-educated white women who
overwhelmingly abandon Trump I don't
know how Trump gets them back so if I
were advising Trump I would say your
entire campaign has to be moms because
how do you change what is what has
occurred in 20 in the last four years if
I'm advising Trump you need to be
running a general election campaign
starting now and you have to appeal
how do you get those people back that is
the sole Focus because buck and I have
talked about this on the show we
certainly talk about it off air it's a
number one conversation let's presume 81
million people let's take the numbers
that are out there 81 million roughly
voted for Biden obviously rig job
benefit of covid changing the rules all
those things I'm not I don't want to
have the debate but 81 million 75
million roughly for Trump
156 million voters how many of those
people are willing to change their mind
in 2024 if we have a rematch how many do
you think actually a million
right I I don't think that I think
people are this goes to the point on
your voting Democrats red red or blue
Bluer I think people are so dug in it's
like trench warfare in politics it's
hard to get the lines to move at this
point so what do you have to do if you
are Trump to me you have to convince all
those women
and this is why the abortion thing I
think is going to play in because I
think they'll also they'll just terrify
you you know your daughter she gets
pregnant she's 14 she's not Trump's
going to keep her from getting an
abortion right like that's the they're
going to go after the Suburban College
moms and it's going to be a challenge so
I I have a slightly different pathway
for Trump if he is in fact the the
nominee on the Republican side
um just because I think what Clay is
saying about the numbers is obviously
true I think Trump's ability to win back
those voters is close to zero
um so the only thing he can flip the
you're saying the soccer moms no chance
they're checked out no chance no chance
and I love Trump I mean I think he's a
great guy I mean when I say that I
actually mean that on a more like
personal I think it's a great guy really
you know Clay and I spent a lot of time
with them I've actually known him and
the family since I was a little kid in
New York too not well but you know I'm
at um different events and things he
went to prom with Ivanka uh I can't do
that here real story Junior Prom it was
like she was a friend I can't believe he
just blew me
here I thought you were this big-headed
dude that just you know talks politics
now I know you got some games yeah it
was it was uh it was no there's no photo
of it online it was Junior it was Junior
Prom right Junior Prom Junior you went
with Ivanka let's relax you're doing
your thing so um yeah I mean Jared's a
very powerful man
by the way they're down there
[Music]
have you guys gone to your uh your wives
or girlfriends like high school reunions
or college reunions have you guys been
to any of those events no oh well so but
this is an experience see who they dated
you're saying yes I mean I did have the
the LA Times reached out to me I saw the
DM somewhere on Facebook and they were
just like we've seen the photos of you
at Ivanka at the Regis prom like would
you like to comment I didn't even
respond I was like what are they gonna
comment like we were the 15 year old
kids like we're there's like priests
everywhere I went to a Jesuit school I
don't even understand what we're talking
about yes but not on the road it was
funny though because she she I mean she
was she's a a total sweetheart and a
really really nice I've always been a
really nice person
um I didn't realize how much at the time
it was it actually was the other girls
who were there who all because she was
really big in the like uh 16 magazine or
you know whatever you know team those
kind of like fashion magazines for young
back in the day man so she was taking
photos with them for like how I was just
like there by myself talking to guys
like yeah you know she's my friend she
came you know she was not my girlfriend
uh I don't want to like overplay this
but um anyway she's a cool lady so I've
known the trumps for a long time back
back to political analysis
um but I think Trump's a great guy I
don't think he can win back those
Suburban moms um I think uh the way that
he wins is uh White working class voters
who for example voted for Obama twice
and then flipped in 2016 in the key
States I think that's it you just gotta
wait again he's got to go he's got to
get Union Union guys with high school
degrees from Wisconsin Michigan to
believe again and to show up for him he
does that I think he can flip enough
votes to do it if he can do the Suburban
soccer mom thing I mean then he's
definitely gonna what about uh DeSantis
if I were advising DeSantis so let's go
back this is the primary advice I think
DeSantis has to go balls to the wall and
I think he has to you know they just
announced that Fox News is going to have
the first debate in August in Milwaukee
I think it's going to be on Rumble as
well this August this uh yeah this
August it'll be the first debate um I
think that DeSantis has to say on the
stage you you lost to Joe Biden you got
your ass kicked by the worst president
that any of us have ever lived through
he's a joke you lost to him
call out Trump directly Andy has to say
and if you're the nominee you will lose
to him again and DeSantis has to say not
only will I not lose to him I will kick
his ass so if you want a president who
is a republican by the way you could
have me for eight years instead of four
with Trump I think he has to go ball you
can't tiptoe up to it because and here's
my thesis on that if he says that to
Trump
I think Trump being called a loser will
be so Furious about the fact that he
gets called a loser that Trump will go
back into his they stole the election
this is why I lost and I think that
doesn't have the same resonance and I
think a lot of people want to win so
badly desantis's play is I'm an
electable version of trump I will be a
more disciplined version of him you saw
the way that I responded to covid uh I
didn't you know defer to Dr Anthony
fauci and everybody else As Long As
Trump did I think he has to go right
after him because here's what I'll say
Trump is way better
in individual like if Trump if you had
Trump into santis in this room right now
or just to meet all your staff out there
I think people would be like holy cow
Trump is amazing on the just gripping
grin the shake the the individual
interaction I don't think DeSantis has
that same Charisma no why would he
Trump's been in an icon for 40 years 50
years he spent his whole life he spent
his whole life shaking hands and
chatting with his daughter went to a
prom with uh yeah a friend Buck over
here that's a big deal so I think you
know the Iowa New Hampshire thing that
will surprise people is Trump's really
good going into McDonald's and like
shaking hands and kissing babies I'm not
sure DeSantis is going to be but and
that's a risky proposition for DeSantis
by the way because if you go all in
after Trump in 24 and he loses how does
that impact things in 28 will people
remember that and understand yeah can
you even think that you gotta go six
years in the future but I think
sometimes people don't gotta go with the
whites right in front of your face they
don't go balls to the wall because
they're worried about the future if he
wants to win he has to like basically
burn the ships behind him and say this
is it and so I I think that it depends
on the Trump approach to dealing with
the scientists once he gets in which I
think is likely to be based on what
we've seen so far just total scorched
Earth although
I do know some people who are in Trump
World who are saying they're a little
surprised that some of the they're so
used to Trump insults just crushing
people right like Little Marco and low
energy Jeb and you know go down the list
right crooked crooked Hillary probably
the best I mean that that one line might
have won in the 2016 election he's so
good at that but even Arden Trump
supporters and voters when he says
Florida's always been great Ron DeSantis
didn't do a good job they go wait no no
no no no no like that's not that's not a
thing you know there are other things
maybe you could say or criticize or go
after a mom but saying that Ron wasn't
good during kovid some of that starts to
feel like he's insulting the
intelligence of the people who support
him the most
um and people like me who voted for him
twice you got to say things you know
they're gonna hit each other right but
it's got to be a clean fight in the
sense that you know I know it's going to
be tough but there's got to be a clean
fight in the sense that it has to be
based in some form so you guys are part
of camp that you believe Trump doesn't
beat Biden but you believe the sentence
could beat Biden directly that's not I
think Trump just to go back to your
point if I were advising Trump I would
say start running the general election
now
because I think he minimizes himself
when he goes after DeSantis what I had
hoped Trump was going to say in
Mar-A-Lago right after he got indicted
uh and had to appear for the arraignment
I wish he had said it's time for all
Republicans to come together I won't say
a single negative word about Ron
DeSantis I'm focused on Biden he's the
enemy yeah he elevates himself and and
he wins that's the way you know there's
no chance he's going down there no but
he should you know that I I think that's
it that's the way that he could win my
concern is you guys watch Game of
Thrones
back in the day like 10 years ago you
didn't watch Game of Thrones oh my God
he's watched one show House of Cards
that was it right that's it wow Game of
Thrones so Game of Thrones we've talked
about this on the show you have trial by
combat
the benefit that Republicans have right
now is you know who your combatant is in
theory it's Joe Biden he's a shitty
fighter he should get his ass kicked
um my concern is if Democrats can pick
their opponent they're trying to put
Trump in the ring against Biden because
they think they can beat Trump
um and so Trump has to be more
sophisticated than he was in 16 and 20
to win and I feel like so many people to
Bucks Point have a preconceived
conclusion of of trump I think DeSantis
would smoke Joe Biden so so
here here's the problem you know and lay
this out my biggest criticism of trump
when he was president had to do with it
it was a no criticism Zone even from the
people who were all in all in on Trump
no one wanted to hear it no one in the
white house around him wanted to hear it
nobody in the media wanted to hear it
you couldn't say hey I don't know if
this is the best approach or if this is
the best and the place where you saw
this the most post was the people that
Trump in term 1 surrounded himself with
to be you know different advisors
cabinet positions he has now even
admitted I mean this is a disaster right
I mean he had scaramucci and Omarosa and
Mike and and which one is the singer
which one is the is the national Michael
Bolton he had John John Bolton thank you
I was going to say it Michael Bolton as
the National Security Michael Bolton I
celebrate his whole catalog
here's the problem Bill Barr we talk I
know Bill Barr Bill Barr is as smart
Allure as you will find anyway Bill
anywhere Bill Barr was not disloyal to
Trump there was no point at which he was
disloyal to Trump he just was loyal to
the law and his job and loyal to Trump
and people gave him all this heat I know
about what was going on right after the
election in that doj in the Attorney
General's office he was turning he was
turning over every stone he was going in
getting screamed at now he's written
about this in his books everybody Moses
by Trump saying you know find this find
that he's like sir we're looking we're
looking I'm trying to what do you want
me to do like we're trying to find it
I'm having people investigate
who's gonna go two things so there's no
criticism Zone which you know whether
it's in business or politics is is bad
and there were things that didn't get
done that should have gotten done and
the first step back by the way was the
disaster which no one really wants to
talk about but it was because you see
what's going on with crime it actually
helped the left get more and more
aggressive on what's happened in the
cities we're talking about but who's
gonna go work for him this time around
given what happened to everybody who
worked from the last time around who's
going to be around him to advise him who
will tell him the truth by the way there
may be answers to these questions he may
bring in great people he may have a new
approach he may have learned a lot from
the past but for me those are big issues
and it's especially on the campaign side
who's gonna run who's gonna run this
question hey and I hope it's not who ran
it in 2012. I got a question for both of
you guys
um so let's say
uh why did why did he lose last time why
did he lose last time 2020 why did he
lose oh man so
I'll go I'll go first on this one okay
so that's such an interesting question
um
there are of course a lot of people who
voted for him who said he didn't lose he
didn't lose that's their that's their
belief and to that I just say that's not
where I'm going but no no no no no I
understand I'm just saying there are a
lot of people that's their approach and
I just say to them they did rig the
system but Joe Biden is President so it
doesn't really matter right so that's
where I come from it from the
perspective of I'm dealing with the
reality today okay why did he lose he
lost because
um other than all the dirty stuff the
Democrats did which we could talk about
for a whole show on its own uh he was
basically missing an action for about
six weeks at the beginning of the BLM
riots and this all happened on Trump's
watch there was about a period there
from the beginning of June right after
George Floyd till middle of July where
the president was effectively not really
doing anything and I think that left a
really bad taste in the mouths of a lot
of of Voters who had come out for him
and also on covid which you know that
becomes very complicated because it's
like once in a century pandemic or
whatever you know he didn't he didn't
fire fauci he he didn't uh he didn't do
as much as I think he could have felt
like the spokesperson for DeSantis
but that's true though these are what
what have I said that's not true the
conversation about fauci but I guess let
me ask a question a different way would
he have one say covet never happens he
wins a Landslide Landslide okay why
though why does he win by Lance because
this this I've spent a ton of time
looking at all the data on this and so
first of all let's start with the
numbers
he came so close and I don't think we
talk about how close it was and when I
say what would you ask do you think
Biden would be Trump I don't know I
think we'll be up till 3 A.M I think
we'll be up till 4 a.m I think we'll be
waiting in 2024 for weeks to find out
what's going to happen in Arizona what
are the you know when is the fire alarms
gonna stop going off in Fulton County
because it's going to be right on the
margins just like 16 was yeah 20 that
and I say this on the show but I think
it's so important if 20 000 people
changed their vote 20 000. that's one
NBA arena in the entire country out of
you know 156 million people who vote in
Wisconsin in Georgia and in Arizona
Trump's president okay so with covid
even with covet right one right right
but I'm talking without covet without
covet he wins a landslide of a landslide
I mean to the extent that you can win a
landslide I mean I think he would have
won Pennsylvania I think he would have
won Michigan I think he would have won
everything he would have flipped some
additional States and I think he may
have flipped Minnesota yeah perfect um I
mean so I think it would have not been
here's my question by the way that's why
your question was so hard just to be
fair because it was the you know once it
was like the asteroid hits the Earth
scenario let me tell you why I'm asking
this question because you know
it's so hard for all of us
you guys are smart there's plenty of
smart guys out there that are presenting
their argument right here's what I think
there's all of us we have a stubborn
side and we have an open-minded side
some of us have a bigger stubborn side
than the other ones some of us have a
big rope of mind inside and the other
one it's good when it's a good balance
but I think you should still stick your
core convictions yet be open-minded I
think that's a good host yeah and then
somebody that you listen to and you're
able to so okay so if he would have won
by a landslide
if coven never happened and he had
already fired a [__] ton of people
so for that point to say well you know
so many people just didn't want to go
you can criticize with them yeah I agree
you can jump you can say this because
everything has to be perfect like under
his watch it's as if he can never make a
mistake I agree that's that's a weakness
but but you still would have won a
landslide even he did yeah okay so what
else did he do the economy was great
this was great I was over borders
nowhere no Isis you know Isis used to be
a topic of discussion if we did podcasts
right now six years ago all we're
talking about is Isis Isis Isis we don't
talk about Isis if you were to go search
how many times you talk about Isis you
don't talk about okay so how about we go
to Afghanistan we talk about Ukraine
Russia would that have happened the
trade China how we bullied them he got
him in their place hey Huawei lady CFO
is in Canada is doing deals with Iran
while we can no longer do business in
U.S 33 doctor there were so many of
these things that was going on that you
felt like okay we can't be bullied I
kind of like this and there's no war
economy is good I'm growing I'm doing
business
now you know we had Giuliani on I don't
know what it was last week we had a live
podcast it was Giuliani and Dave Rubin
it was great because Ruben is more
DeSantis and giuliani's going to be
loyal to Trump which makes it a very
good show where we can kind of go back
and forth
you know in julianas well let me tell
you you know what happened with the rig
they're like no I'm like yeah it's it's
it's just not attractive you know it's
not gonna work because you know when my
kids complain about losing that the
other person cheated I you don't get
anything from me that weekend that's not
attractive to me I've lost because
others cheated and you know get stronger
get better do any of that stuff that you
got to be doing so for me the thing and
I'll turn it over to you if he would
have won with a landslide with no covet
Landslide there is no covet today
zero covet is gone okay
should he not win by a landslide today
because America would be okay with his
policies how much has changed between
the landslide take out covet
than today so
this is going to annoy me to say but I
think it's true and it's proven by the
data so I'm not happy with this reality
but I think it is a reality
um you know I would gladly vote for
Donald Trump again and I think he'd be a
very good president again but everything
that you're setting up for this
historical counterfactual you also have
to put in there what does the whole
January 6th thing do not for me because
I think the media is completely
overplayed it and they call it an
Insurrection and I know what an
Insurrection looks like I was in the CIA
it wasn't an Insurrection but they do
this because they think it's effective
with moderates and independent well it
was a it was effective in 2022 I hate
that's that's what you look at the
candidates who didn't win who should
have won and they were all focused in on
the election and they were too tied to
that aspect from his credibility today
they did Russia for three years and they
stopped talking about it after Durham
came out and they silence you know so I
agree with you but I'm saying it's I'm
telling you the January 6th thing is
going to make it harder to win
independence the next time round because
there's this fatigue with people they're
like uh so the media is going to do the
propaganda the craziness
so what are Independence tired of Biden
with
what what are Independents sick of Biden
with today let me flip it on you and
just ask this yeah okay flip it flip it
back and forth 81 let's assume that the
Voting is accurate 81 million people
voted against Donald Trump sure they did
not vote for Joe Biden we could drive
around anywhere in South Florida and
find the Biden voters none of them like
Joe Biden there were no uh Biden signs
on anybody's law and there's no Biden
bumper stickers I mean Joe Biden had a
anti-trump if Joe Biden had a rally in
Miami nobody is showing up so my
question this is what we were hitting on
earlier that I think everybody out there
if you objectively look at it is we live
in a world where people make up their
mind and I appreciate what you're saying
you have a core set of values but you're
willing to look at the data and change
your mind that's not most people
those 81 million people have convinced
themselves on some level that Trump is
Hitler right so in order for Trump to
win
you have to believe one of two things uh
you asked the question how many people
are actually persuadable let's say 156
million people voted maybe a million
people are actually willing to change
their votes I mean I I I like they still
the same people that voted for Bush that
voted for Obama that ended up voting for
Trump they're going to but there's like
one million
if you're gonna make I do believe in 20
without covid Trump wins big but I think
that the situation has changed in 24
because all of those people have now
come in and they have put themselves in
the camp of hey I am of the opinion that
uh Donald Trump is wrong so you have to
get those people to change their mind or
you have to convince me and maybe you
could that way less people are going to
vote in 24 because it's not going to be
as tumultuous
I'll put this out there because I've
said this on the radio show uh Patrick
as an amateur no no go for it if if the
if they rolled out Joe Biden drooling on
himself with a blanket across his knees
every Democrat that you and I know who
voted from the last time around will
come out and vote for him again without
exception because they vote they vote
they vote
is the perfect example of this they vote
for the party Machinery yeah they do not
vote for the candidate even speak they
do not care he won by four points and
one of the biggest talks and you know
why by the way we're gonna we're gonna
lose we're gonna lose Pennsylvania again
I have a couple friends who have run for
Congress there and Senate there and
we're going to lose Pennsylvania again
because the Democrats are better
organized better funded and pay more
attention to how to win in that state
whereas we have a lot of big voices who
are saying Oh but you know we should all
vote on Election Day the Democrats in
Pennsylvania other places or how do we
maximize our efficiency in getting the
most votes counted legally or illegally
if they can get away with it whatever it
doesn't matter they're just trying to
win all right so so let's let's look at
this what's changed so we have all
agreed here including yourself if kovit
doesn't happen Trump wins my Landslide
we've all agreed on that that Trump's
gonna electoral Landslide by the way he
might not have won the popular vote of
course he would be president yeah
so fine so and we all agree that covet
is not the main issue top five issue
today not even top 10 issue today as it
was two years ago thank God there should
be by the way a reckoning I'm glad yeah
so so so that main issue that we were
all obsessed with for two and a half
years or let me rephrase it we were
forced to be obsessed yeah for two and a
half years that's gone that main issue
is gone no problem let's see what has
changed in the last three years on top
of what you just said you're saying well
you know you have to realize the January
6th that this the this did that no
problem in the last three years a guy
named Elon muskba Twitter in the last
three years a guy named Joe Rogan
who was a pot smoking
you know psychedelics
Ayahuasca UFC guy that was willing to
vote for Bernie Sanders says yeah to say
things you gotta vote Republican yeah no
one in a million years would have
guessed he would say that Elon Musk
would have said that and now they own it
now rumble's creating a ton of momentum
and on top of that let's see what else
has changed let's see what else has
changed
we didn't have this [__] with
transgender stuff a few years ago okay
so so let me get this straight you talk
about moms how many moms have daughters
whether they're Republican Or democrats
50 of it let's just reuse the number 50
every other six that's born it's a girl
okay how many daughters you know are
sitting there talking to Mom and say Mom
but I can't beat him but I can't beat
him I don't know how to beat him okay we
didn't have that now it's front and
center everywhere it's okay let him beat
it because if they identify they can do
this moms are sitting there Democrats
are probably saying I'm sorry man I was
a Democrat Bill Clinton Democrat I'm
even Obama democrat this [__] doesn't
make any sense I'm not a Democrat if I
have to subscribe to this this is out of
control let me continue let me continue
this is me that you're describing except
I'm a dude so so I'm going to continue
and I'm gonna you got three boys imagine
the mom with a girl right so I got two
boys two girls you're thinking dude you
ain't gonna do that and embarrass my
daughter as a freaking guy get that out
of here yeah what are you talking about
what happened to protecting women that
creates rage right and I'm not willing
you to allow you to bully my daughter no
it doesn't matter politically I'm still
daughter over politics I believe moms
are daughter over politics fine let's
continue
this Dylan Mulvaney stuff that's going
on even more stuff education you're
trying to teach my kids about gay you
know whatever first grade second grade
third grade kind of weird okay let's
give the Roe v way to the other side
which has changed that's massive I do
believe that is massive that we've had
in the last yeah I think January 6
people are like listen I get it yes a
year ago I don't think people are going
to Care six months from now I don't
think I'm gonna care 12 months from now
so where I'm going with this is the
final one I have a whole different view
with DeSantis I think descent is a stud
of a guy and I think the scientist needs
a different marketing team and my
criticism for descent is not policies my
the criticism For The Senses more
marketing than it's anything else so for
me when when I sit there and I think
about that it's okay you say a lot has
changed but I think a lot has changed to
favor him not to hurt him I think a lot
of people that wouldn't have voted from
three years ago are sitting there saying
do that I lied to him I can't stand that
freaking guy but let me tell you this
this Hillary Ronan lady who's in
District 9 of San Francisco board who
just two years ago said hear me out I am
about defunding the police and now she's
crying Talking nobody showed up they're
not putting the funds in we need more
cops here no [__] Sherlock and she just
got off of Twitter yesterday because now
you realize the amount of hypocrisy that
people even in San Francisco Nick Sarah
Foster comes out and says what the hell
are you talking about these are liberal
politicians as a liberal myself she's
saying these are the policies that [__]
we didn't have three years ago so to me
all I'm saying is I'm not saying you're
right or you're wrong all I'm saying is
none of us know yet fully what's really
going to be the turnout but I don't
think it's that camper they're like well
I just don't think it's going to be
Biden I just don't think it's going to
be Biden I I don't think we all know yet
so a few thoughts that came to mind when
you're when you're talking about this
additional perspective one is
um I shared the sense that January 6 was
a nothing Burger in terms of the way
people would vote until the midterms
that we just had and then looking at the
data for who came out and who didn't
there were a lot of college-educated
white voters specifically often
Independents but even some sort of soft
Republicans who wouldn't come out for
candidates in Arizona and Pennsylvania
and places we needed to win that were
you know January 6th and Trump I think
are kind of obviously very tied together
so that was that was what the data
showed there so I was I feel like I was
wrong on that I was we were making jokes
about it we're like they're having these
hearings it's so stupid there were
people taking photos I'm not looking at
it for oh so you know I can't believe in
Trump and everything else I'm just
saying they ran this game plan I think
it worked pretty well from the last time
I'm worried it would work for them again
in the National whether that's true or
not by the way I agree with you no one
can predict future and anybody says they
can is living in a fantasy
um the data right now also and the
polling the problem with the polling is
in 2022 and we got caught on the wrong
side of this unfortunately I think
everybody did we thought it was going to
be a much better election for
Republicans than it was polling is
obviously a little bit sketchy but right
now all the polling pretty consistently
shows Donald Trump losing in a
head-to-head to Joe Biden whereas it
doesn't show that with Ron DeSantis so I
think there's something there again it's
not you know it doesn't prove the uh so
let's play that card sure let's let's
buy the polls okay which obviously polls
historically have always been right we
have to travel so but let's play that
game with these polls no problem
um
if they're right
and you're the Democrat
why the hell are you getting in the way
your enemy let him win
you mean Let Me Explain If you think
these polls are right
why have this Alvin guy go out there and
hey you know let's go do this and
because he did this and let's go do that
and because he did that and I was going
no no no hey Mr Democratic strategist
polls you guys are so great at it you
think Biden's gonna beat him head on no
problem get out of his way so I think to
your point I think the strategy is they
know that the charges help him in the
Republican primary and they hurt him in
the general so I think the the chess
move here is the charges make it more
likely that Trump is the opposition
people saying that and I think and by
the way I'd love to agreed with
everything that you were just saying
that was me I voted for Obama in 2008
and 2012. for much of my life before
like all the the Democrats went insane I
was a persuadable voter right I look at
the logic I look at the data Buck was
reading this is will yeah when he was 14
years old and like well enough monthly
wearing my boat shoes
for the whole time I was a radical
moderate for much of my career but the
you know Elon Musk has shared this Meme
and I think it you know like I don't
know you guys have it or it shows you
like uh if you'll pull it up for people
who have not seen it it kind of
perfectly epitomizes my political value
uh uh Evolution like I was very I've
always been kind of middle of the road
rational I'm persuadable right like hey
you make a rational logical argument
I'll buy into it Democrats have gone
fully insane which is why you're gonna
love the book that I've got coming out
in August because it's all about I'm
super fired up I would hammer home if I
could this idea that you can have a
[__] dude decide he's a girl
sit out for a year and then he becomes a
women's champion is batshit insane right
I think there are lots of Democrats have
become insane you want them to pull up
where it shows like a stick figure
standing you have like the political
spectrum and if you look at it it's like
hey here was me in 2008 and you might
just be a little bit left of center and
then the Democrats have run so far I've
had it a minute ago they've run so far
left wing that's it that's the one
that's it
um and if you zoom in on this there you
go 2008 there's me like that's me I'm a
little bit left of center maybe like
whatever and then 2012 and then like now
I'm a radical like Buck sees it I'm a
right-wing extremist I'm a conspiracy
theorist I'm a crazy man and I haven't
really changed the country's gone insane
and I I also think that the who does
that benefit though so who does that
benefit like for for when you say that
you know a lot of people agree with that
dude musk would never come out and say
vote Republican so how much influence
does musk have how much influence does
Rogan have so think about this let's
actually process this together 81.75
okay 81.75 now we both know who Rogan
and musk would get behind yep we both
know who it is and it's the santis it's
not Trump okay but I do think they would
vote Trump uh over I agree yeah if it
does come down to that they their number
one is the scientist over Trump we can
all agree on that it's very obvious you
know hey I believe the last age for you
to run for office 69 years old we all
remember all that fun we agree by the
way Rupert Murdoch would be in that camp
too right like uh he's basically said to
Sam Schwartzman so is a lot of different
guys guys that the money guys there's a
lot of guys that are in that camp right
now okay fine
so 81.75 so the day comes debate August
Fox is over say boom do we have to pick
and choose who it is it's Trump okay
so if it's Trump we know if it's the
santis what's gonna happen schwartzman's
gonna get behind this guy's getting
about musk is going to get they're going
to campaign for him the Rogan DeSantis
podcast is going to be massive okay
hopefully if the centers have a
marketing team kind of teach them how to
connect with the audience because the
one he did with Pierce was a flop okay
and his book didn't do that well I read
the book I love the book but I said how
come other people are not feeling the
same way about the book right so
so then
Trump is a candidate musk and Rogan have
a choice where they have to choose
between Trump or Biden yep we both know
whether they want to or not they're
probably going to go Trump yep not
because of trump but they're going to
say we're doing the same vote that
people did in 2020 we're doing that
strategy which is what anything but
Bible okay perfect
how much influence you think the richest
man in America and the number one
podcaster in the world has not not
enough to switch the election what do
you think
honestly I mean so so you've gotta there
why do they come to mind and why are
they so important right now what do you
mean but they could swing not very many
give me a number what do you think it is
I mean in the in the total of the the
entire U.S election I mean not enough to
even win a single year a hundred
thousand you think that's small oh I
think of the 156 million people who and
and by the way 156 million people who
have already voted right you think it's
a hundred thousand swings because do you
have to convince people that they're
wrong yeah and the other part of this is
that we're leaving out we're leaving out
I refer to it as the apparatus
specifically because of the Soviet
connection
um but the Democrat apparatus in this
country we're talking about Elon you're
talking about okay what about Zuckerberg
what about Bezos what about Soros what
about I mean go down the list what about
CBS News
16. Trump beat those guys he okay now
that was a very specific set of circles
I was actually a right-wing commentator
at CNN when they still had those in 20
to 2015 2016. so I saw the evolution
there they completely misplayed how to
they were running Trump live on CNN they
gave him billions of dollars of free
media because they thought he was such a
joke he was such a clown that it amused
Their audience gave them great numbers
and he was and he was gonna they've been
wrong before strategically look they
could be wrong again but I'm just saying
what they did in 2016 they didn't do in
2020 and they wouldn't do again which is
allow Trump to harness he people forget
they initially used fake news as really
as an attack on Trump supporters they
were believing fake news about the
Russia stuff on Facebook that was that
percolated then Trump turned around and
said no no it's not about believing some
internet post CNN is fake news he was
able to do this Jujitsu against the
entire media apparatus that it's just
they learned the lesson unfortunately in
2020 which is why they did all the
suppression all the things they did so
yeah we've got our guys who are trying
to help I think Elon is doing more for
democracy and Free Speech in America
than almost any other person you can
think of but there's so much arrayed
against and when you look at the way
they can even quantify this stuff even
the like CBS you talk about like the
scene you know senior citizens watching
cable news CBS News still gets like five
million people watching a night and it
is Democrat propaganda you know four
years though they've had four years
that's not a change though oh I'm not
saying all I'm saying is the change of
what an ilano non-worgan were three
years ago versus what they are today and
there's a lot of guys like that in the
marketplace there's not just those two I
mean he collectively there's hundreds of
guys like that in the comedy space in
the Sports World in the you know you're
you're preaching my book because my
argument is find things that 70 percent
of people agree with and slam the
Democrats on them all day dudes deciding
to be girls and kick people's ass the
fact that I've I've been arguing this if
I were Trump I would go balls to the
wall on defending comedians right the
idea that you could be offended by a
joke is total [__] to me right the
entire purpose of Comedy is to push the
bounds of acceptable discourse the idea
that a comedian gets that Kevin Hart
can't host the Oscars because he made a
joke about uh a gay joke or that Dave
Chappelle can't say this because it's
offensive to transgender like whatever
the goal of Comedy is to ridicule
everyone evenly and if Trump could lean
into that if DeSantis could lean into
that find these things that 70 percent
of people agree with and Hammer them
over and over and over again then I
think you can start to move things a
little bit but to be fair I wasn't
really you because you pointed out you
kept saying it's not different okay but
for example the move even of the big big
donors to DeSantis fro instead of trump
right a lot of that is just because
there's a there's a little more
hesitation a little more oh I don't know
because of January 6 for some of those
people I'm just I wish it were not true
I think it shouldn't be true but that is
true right now that is most likely by
the way we're going to get Trump versus
Biden again like if you told me right
now hey you have to put money down on
the debate and this is what I would say
to you guys I'm curious what you guys
think about this what's the number one
worst thing about Biden from an election
2024 perspective number one weakness
I think it's age overwhelmingly right so
to so many people cosmetically make
decisions on who to vote for
78 year old that's how old he would be
Donald Trump on the stage against 82
year old Joe Biden number one reaction
people are going to have is both these
guys are too old Trump even though he's
far more in control of his faculties and
the fact that Biden can't even speak the
age thing gets canceled out if Trump is
the nominee I mean I would just say I
told a big Republican donor just a few
nights ago we had we had dinner and uh
down in down in Miami and they asked me
what do you think I said um I said I
will not throw in for either side either
privately or publicly I won't I'm not
I'm either DeSantis or Trump whoever
wins and I'm very open about that but I
said if you're asking me for odds as to
who's going to win the primary I'd give
you two to one odds that Donald Trump
wins the primary
I agree with him 100 on that and then
the second part of this is
if you put DeSantis or Nikki Haley or
somebody younger on the stage against
Biden I think those people win big
because a lot of people out there just
look at it and say we can't have a
president who's 82 years old
like Joe Biden legitimately could could
Joe Biden do any job at your business
yeah I I think it's even more it's even
more specifically than you know Joe
Biden that's the perception the
persuadables right like I'm voting for
what I'm voting for because I've
believed in the same basic principles
since I was a teenager effectively in
the Constitution all this kind of stuff
right but for the people that could go
either way or could show up or not show
up the age thing with Joe Biden I think
could be big because remember they're
not they're not one-issue voters on the
economy or the Border or anything else
they're kind of thinking about a whole
range of things and they look at this
guy and he's I mean it's it's kind of
sad I mean he's decrepit right but what
we've seen with fetterman is that that
will not stop them one bit that will not
stop it comes down to juxtaposition if
you've got a 78 year old guy an 82 year
old guy it's like they are they've
already been around the block a million
times there were known Commodities
everybody knows them you get a young
fresh Ron DeSantis on there
juxtaposition versus an old sleepy Joe
it's gonna be alarming to Moses that's
why I said trial by combat the benefit
Republicans have is they know who
is going to be a nominee and that's how
Biden got selected they knew Trump was
going to be in the ring and they said
he's the less uh Dangerous by the way I
built on what Buck said we've got such a
big audience on radio you asked the
question about endorsements
um we don't ever want to be in the
position of hey you should vote for this
guy or that guy in a primary we're
obviously going to be a billion percent
behind Trump DeSantis Nikki Haley
whoever the nominee is because Biden is
such a disaster right and so that's
where we really kind of Mark that's our
audience I spent a lot of time reminding
because in our audience uh on radio we
have people who are calling in saying
you guys are way too pro-trump and we
people calling in who are saying you're
way too protestantas and they also
something I'm never going to listen
again you're too Pro Trump or two pro to
Santa every day every day we're getting
we're getting this from both sides and I
try to remind them if you're a trump guy
you're a Santa's guy you are someone who
probably agrees on 90 plus of everything
happening in America today you're on the
same team you're trying to figure out
who the captain of the team is going to
be that's going to get a little lost
during the primary I know it's big boy
stuff I understand that but I hope that
people keep that in mind as we go
forward here because you know what you
don't want is to get in a situation
where someone is so damaged and and you
know so hobbled from the primary that
they actually kind of Limp into the
general right before Trump runs as a
third party which is everybody's worst
that's the worst Cosmic scenario
scenario if somebody else my my ideas
are a whole different thing like I'm I'm
waiting for the census Camp to really
you know sometimes you think you have a
lot of attempt to create momentum you
don't their Camp has a shot they have a
shot but when's the last time you hear
the story about this but he's not a
candidate yet it doesn't matter you
still start marketing there's many
people that weren't candidates that they
were branding and marketing way before
so well the book wasn't attempted that
but I think your point about it but he
didn't do a good job promoting his book
I'm sorry that book was a lazy method of
marketing go on so many he that book
should be in top ten for six straight
months if you would have gone has it
gone on your podcast has he talked to
you guys on radio but not in a while
so let me get this straight you guys
replace rush and he hasn't come on to
you I understand you don't want to come
here because I challenge all the time
you guys support him you replace Rush he
hasn't been on your podcast how he came
on he came on by the way and here's my
question before you defend him since the
launch of the book I'm trying to
remember
he came on the day the book released
there we go and did he promote the book
yeah for 10 minutes I mean he was on for
a 10 minute hit that's not really but
that's not really no I mean I you're
preaching the choir like I I think I
think he is so Mark I think he
is a strong leader I think he has an
incredible resume I I don't know why
they're not telling the story it's
almost as if he's not gonna run if
you're not going to run then I support
it on what you're doing maybe you're not
going to be running and that's your
strategy and none of us know [__] fine
but if you are gonna run
what's he gonna do if he gets on your
post get Podcast for an hour all he's
gonna get is nice questions and he's
going to be able to defend himself and
the audience is going to see a different
side of him how many people like that
could he have gone on you making Kelly
so many different places he could have
gone up no why don't you well because he
hasn't announced it yet but you launched
a damn book I I was the marketing guy so
I think the Trump people have landed so
many blows
it's a one-way war and a one-way War
only goes in One Direction so far that's
the way it's I think when you have the
resume that he has all you have to say
is the answer he keeps giving listen
guys everybody wants it to be me against
Trump I'm not going to fall for that all
I'm going to tell you is our resume I
won by 34 000 most the first time yeah
because Trump helped us out yes that is
true he said in his book multiple times
second time one and a half million that
wasn't without the help here's who we
were able to convert while the states
were doing this we went against the
grain they said this we did this here's
what happened to Florida look how many
people are coming to us from New York
we're recruiting cops he just have to
say that like there was one time I saw a
video they were making fun of uh the
rock to promote a movie and he was on 20
different interviews and he used the
same exact line you know go look at him
he's Jesus said that's he what he's
supposed to do you're supposed to go say
that to different audiences even if
people catch you or not that's part of
your job you're gonna have to have us
back in the summer when he's a candidate
so we can actually see
pay attention to one date uh the Florida
legislative session men's May 5th yeah
yeah so
okay so may that's a month from now so
the analysis say second third week of
May so he's got nine months after you
launched your book that you haven't
promoted yet what are you going to go
back and re-promote a book that you
launched three months ago I'm a marketer
guys I'm not a politician I'm a marketer
from the marketing standpoint that's not
a good marketing strategy you don't
think he's going to hit the Blitzkrieg
this summer you don't think he's going
to decide that when he's actually
running as a candidate all of a sudden
you're probably not going to get him out
of your green room
because I think he's got a great resume
and I'm just to me you know you know
when the coach gets upset at Steph Curry
one game I'll never forget it's like can
I ask you why you're not shooting threes
you shot two threes today what's the
matter with you what's the matter with
you shoot the damn threes you're our
best guy go
play ball bro let's go like the [__]
you're right and then all the teammates
are like dude I don't care if you go
0410 yeah you're the best three-point
shooter go let's roll that's the part
where it's like this is a phenomenal
candidate you have an incredible resume
coming from the biggest [__] show for
two and a half years and you came up
above everybody there's not a governor
that's a bot for him in America during
covet with all the manipulation
everybody targeting his ass he stood out
the more you wait the more those stories
are gone what are we doing like who the
hell is going out there speaking for you
who's going out there selling this stuff
for you my my frustration is a complete
different frustration you've got nothing
to do with policy one quick thing I know
you want to get the Elon thing I just
would say there are a lot of people that
I think would speak out about that stuff
on the right and they are afraid of
trump
if there are people like that you should
resign because if you're doing this type
of stuff you know I never forget this
there was a uh uh a book I read Business
book I wish I want to give this guy
credit I don't know who wrote it when I
found out I'm gonna give the credit when
you're coming up you always have these
two or three names that you think you
need because without them you're never
going to be as big you know you're doing
a show oh my God if we land that
interview oh my God if we raise money
from that guy oh my god listen man
you think you need that one interview
that one gets that whenever to validate
you if you're good enough and you're
fair with your audience and you're
straight up and there's a part of you
that respects the audience but there's a
part of you that's not going to Cave
into your audience trashing you because
you don't say what they want you to say
I'm not doing that bro this is what I
believe you don't like it go talk to
somebody else that you think you're
going to agree with 100 of time that's
not my ass to the people that are afraid
of that they should quit today because
they don't belong in a journalistic
world talk [__] to both sides give your
opinion support give your values and
principles and then from there on see
what happens defend your values and
principles I'm very open about the
values and principles I defend you guys
got the top show radio
he I'm sorry guys I'm I'm preaching to
the choir I would call into our show
unscheduled all the time to talk for
five to seven minutes you know who did
that this guy named Donald yeah he did
that all the time best story I've got
for Trump really quickly first time I
had him on the radio show
he's president the United States he
called the show himself
you guys know the pr apparatus that
exists for like low-level non-inities he
would call the show himself and come on
you call that a hustler that's what you
call that and you know what I respect
the hustle he's a marketer yeah and and
by the way you're going against a
marketer yep
you're going against the market or you
ain't going again you beat him you could
beat the other guy it's a it's almost
like you know sometimes there's an NBA
championship and you're like this ain't
a freaking Championship nobody watches
it because the championship was the
Eastern Conference Finals the hell are
we doing here you beat the Eastern
Conference Final you could win it all
and get a chip today there's a lot could
change between now and five years from
now four years from now so I don't know
I'm my my level of uh
frustration is that you think you have
more time than you actually have where
is the sense of urgency where is that
where's the sense of urgency with that
the comparison though to understanding
the no one has understood the media and
been the same kind of force that Donald
Trump has been that's your opponent so
that no I yeah so you know what that
means though here's what that means you
know what I do this is what I do from if
I'm the sentences camp Hey Schwartzman
do you really support us yes
who's the best marketer you know we want
to meet with them hey XYZ musk you
support us yes who's the best Market we
can hire for the next two years are you
willing to help us find that guy and you
don't think musk know that what David
sacks knows that guy or Rogan has these
calls bro let's use our contact to put a
super ass team together to play ball and
I guarantee you if you hired a super
team to to work with you if some people
may say well maybe he's done that nobody
knows about it really you think the
super team would have allowed the book
to do what it did I don't think so I
think it would have been a complete
different story again to me he's
president Trump's president we're fine
because we need somebody that's strong
to fight off against all the [__]
that's going on in the world today this
is not a picking favorite this is about
the the more both sides are fighting
their arguments in a better way we have
a better chance of having somebody when
I just don't see them playing offense
it's disappointing but again I may be
wrong I'm not a political strategist I'm
a pure marketer and a strategist from
the sense of Business Point not from
when I'm competing with different people
in the insurance space I have to figure
out a way what that guy's strength is
what my weakness is what his weaknesses
what my strength is these are not
complicated conversations to be having
so I just don't know who they're hiring
behind closed doors hey musk you really
want me to win I need your help you
don't think musk would help them do you
think they've had that meeting before I
hope they have do you think they're
having he's coming to Miami must end it
a month I hope he's meeting with the
centers if they had these meetings has
he sat down with broken is he having
these conversations when Schwartzman
maybe they are maybe they're not but
they have access to these people to hire
so if you really want me show up
show up give me some of those guys you
asked the question what 2024 what's
going to matter the most I think the
most normal candidate will win
I think the thing that the country wants
is normalcy well we wanted that in 2020
and well Biden sold that he would bring
this right he's failed this is and the
the problem we Face against Biden I tell
the audiences every time we're
discussing what we're facing in 2024 is
that the Joe Biden that you are going to
be running against in the general
election is not the Joe Biden who has
been governing meaning he's going to be
the guy he's like I love police police
are great you know I love cops yeah
we're going to make you safe he's going
to do all the stuff that you're seeing
from the actual Democrat Party in terms
of governance legislation they want that
will be largely pushed aside and Joe
Biden the cuddly old grandpa that
everyone knows is you know just down the
middle in a straight shooter that's who
you're running against it's a it's a
what are the most important states to
win for Biden and Trump Arizona
Wisconsin Michigan Pennsylvania Georgia
okay so take those four let's just say
four or five right
has the centers done a book tour in
those places even pre-announcing
he was just up in Michigan I know that I
mean to your point I would go ahead and
say pick a a VP candidate and take one
of those States off the board like to me
if I were to santis I I'm part of my
launch I'd be like I'm taking Brian I'm
gonna tell you this right now when you
see when it's announced Trump is going
to pick somebody that Trump likes and
not somebody that necessarily is going
to help deliver the election from in
2024 because that's just how he thinks
let's do one last story because I know
you guys gotta we got a heart stop here
so Riley Gaines rips Nike for
partnership with trans influencer Dylan
Mulvaney they can't forget taking my
money former University Kentucky swimmer
Riley games criticized Nike decision to
make transgender influencer Dylan
mulvania spokesperson stating that the
mockery Mulvaney deals deal makes of
women is incredibly degrading and that
Nike can forget taking my money gains uh
recently experienced physical assault
after speech she gave at San Francisco
State University about saving women's
sports at a turning point USA and
Leadership Institute event on campus she
accused
Fox feminist of uh being uh scared to
act after the incident and campus police
of being terrified to do their job as
they did not want to be accused of being
racist for protecting gains who is white
what are your thoughts about the story
of Nike not surprising at all that
there's been such a backlash too when
you think about how crazy this is
they're having a man with no breasts try
to sell sports bras but more than that
uh which you would just think the basic
physics and and physicality would matter
more the the bigger point I think you're
seeing is what I've been I've been
saying on the show for a long time
people understand transgender so so just
defund the police isn't really about
defunding the police defund police is
actually a step if you listen to the
true hardcore left in abolition of
police so that's the actual position
defund is always a step on the way they
want to get rid of all police
departments and actually all prisons so
it's crazy but that's the belief the
real belief of transgenderism is not
that the these are people who you know
are deserving of of dignity and to be
treated that's that's of course that's a
given right any moral person is going to
treat a person with dignity and kindness
and and have the full protection of the
law uh and their position isn't just to
be polite to them it is this is a woman
indistinguishable in all facets in every
way from other women they are demanding
that you obey and believe a lie an
obvious and objective lie and anything
short of your belief in that lie will
always be unacceptable this is why they
have the women can men can get pregnant
too and men can menstruate and all these
things they're not just saying this
because they're trying to create
language that's confusing they're saying
it because a man with a penis through
transgender ideology and it is purely it
is not about people who are intersex it
is purely about a psychological State
can become fully female and I've even
said this to Clay they've started to say
if you're a heterosexual male and you
are not attracted to transgender people
a transgender woman for example uh you
are transphobic that has started to
happen because that is actually
ridiculous guys I'm sorry I've been so
emotional today I just got my period and
you know things thank God I just got a
tampon uh Tampax sponsorship thank you
for that I I look at this and this is
where I came from the World of Sports
and this to me is something that Sports
is the ultimate meritocracy it's the
best man or woman
or woman and so you guys know I mean you
were at the UFC event right we have
weight classes in UFC uh if you play
high school sports the the biggest high
schools don't compete against the
smallest high schools I coach 12 year
old you know youth basketball and
baseball if I suddenly showed up with a
16 year old to play everybody would say
this is ridiculous this is a 70 30 80 20
issue and I think this is an example of
something where I said the goal is
normalcy this ain't normal okay and
they're trying to make it seem normal
and this I'm sure you guys have seen it
you know from a marketing perspective
if Nike was making see this is where
Kaepernick ties into me with this story
Colin Kaepernick was the first person in
sports that Nike hired and tried to give
an endorsement deal to that was not
Elite in his sport
now they have moved into we're just
gonna grab random fake chicks and make
them try to sell gear if Nike came out
and they said hey clay and buck you guys
have the biggest Radio Show in the
country we want to advertise with you
simultaneously we want to advertise to
the trans Community like we're trying to
appeal to 100 of the population I would
nod my head and say okay
they would never buy a a an
advertisement on the clay and buck show
right no we're two we're two toxic the
guy who pretends he's a woman and has a
sports bra for no reason is brand
perfect for you yes yeah and so I think
it's it's indicative of how crazy that
that analogy again that little graphic
of where we've gone in 2008 if you had
said if Barack Obama had run for
president and said I think chicks with
dicks should be able to compete against
women people would have said it's crazy
people forgot Barack Obama wasn't
opposed to gay marriage in 08 right he
ran on the videos everywhere you can
find he ran on we should never change
the marital standard it's crazy that's
just 15 years ago 2008 you want to blow
people's mind 2008 Obama would be a
republican campaign now
on many issues two things has that I
always say that's not true
beat Obama unlike a few issues would be
a republican because the left has gone
so far left okay can we do the musk
thing before we wrap up let's do the
musk clip real quick before we wrap up
uh play the two minute one not the four
minute one there's two of them yeah that
one right there perfect let's let's so
this is Elon Musk sitting down with BBC
reporter I think his name is James
Clayton and it starts with the BBC guy
interviewing Elon it flips very quickly
they're doing Twitter spaces at the same
time smart on Elon Musk side so they
can't cut and not play all the clips
here's uh here's musk and Clayton
describe a hateful thing yeah yeah I
mean you know this content that will
solicit a reaction something that may
include something that is slightly
racist or slightly sexist those kinds of
those kinds of things so you think if
something is slightly sexist it should
be banned
I'm asking for specific examples
um and if and you just said that if
something is slightly sexist that's
hateful content does that mean that it
should be bad well you've asked me
you've asked me whether my feed whether
it's got less or more I'd say it's got
slightly more that's why I'm asking for
examples can I can you name one example
I honestly don't need honestly I can't
name a single example I'll tell you why
because I don't actually use that for
you feed anymore because I just don't
particularly like it a lot of people a
lot of people are quite similar I I only
only you said you've seen more hitful
content but you can't name a single
example not even one I'm not sure I've
used that fee for the last
three or four weeks tonight well then
how did you see the headboard contact
because I've been I've been using I've
been using Twitter since you've taken
over for the last six months okay so
then you must have at some point seen
that you're for you hateful content I'm
asking for one example right you can't
give a simple way and I'm saying I I say
so that you don't know what you're
talking about yeah
a single example of hateful content not
even one tweet and yet you're claimed
that the hateful content was high well
that's a false no what I could just lied
what no no
uh there are many uh organizations that
say that that kind of information is on
the rise now whether whether it has a
maybe one example I mean there's someone
like this the Strategic dialogue
Institute in the U in the UK they will
say that so because people will say all
sorts of nonsense I'm literally asking
for a single example and you can't name
one right and as I already said I don't
use that feed but how would you know
that I don't think this is getting
anything you literally said you
experienced more hateful content and
then couldn't name a single example
right and as I said that's absurd I
haven't I haven't actually looked at
that feed and how would you know this
beautiful content because I'm saying
that's what I saw two weeks ago an exact
example let's move on
let's move on so you get knocked out and
you're like hey let's go ahead and uh
on the canvas uh no that's the
dissection of a media talking point in
real time it was pretty amazing my
reaction is one you kind of hit it at
this before I don't know why any person
would agree to anything that is not
going to be aired in its entirety who is
in a prominent position in other words
if you want to interview me that's fine
the whole thing has to Air and then
people can listen to the whole thing in
context the fact that you know what
Trump would still sit and allow anybody
to interview him like you're a super
busy guy and I would say the same thing
to Sanders or anybody else you want me
for an hour boom we're talking for the
entire hour and it all goes public and
I'm bringing my own crew to record it
because if you try to cut and paste what
I said I won't allow that and I think
this is what you get I think that's what
people crave that authenticity because
so much of what we are marinated in on a
day-to-day basis is total [__] so
and people cut through it and they
recognize it the left is much better at
molding words for political purposes
than we are they're constantly changing
and policing language to that end when
they say hateful what they want is for
people to think that they're talking
about hate speech and what they really
mean by hateful is anything that I don't
like anything that bothers me anything
that challenges my assumptions I'm going
to label that hateful and then have in
the minds of a lot of people some
association with oh it must be like
really
ugly racist sexist you know that's
that's hateful no I mean saying like
maybe we should actually enforce
immigration law at the U.S Mexico border
like that they would consider to be
utterly hateful I mean there are things
that that they uh would put in that
bucket that I think no normal person
would ever consider to be hateful but
that's the whole point they want to be
able to control I think there was one
word that that uh that journalists use
that completely ruined his argument and
when he started using the word well
slightly misogynistic slightly
transformed he's like so now slightly is
hateful and and then Elon Musk just
pounced on that it wasn't it was over I
also think the number of people who say
some would say okay
so you know like some people say yeah
people say some people people are saying
that's that's what people are saying
many people probably the best I know
that one they're ugly that's when the
person hasn't done their homework
because he could have easily said he
could have cited two or three different
like organizations and then musk would
have had to attack the organizations but
when he doesn't have any basis
whatsoever and he's just kind of relying
on that ephemeral some people say maybe
you would say it's evident that he
hasn't done his homework and you guys
will know this there's a lot of really
lazy and dumb journalists and they get
credit for being way smarter than they
actually are because most people won't
go after them most are activists not
journalists well listen guys this was
phenomenal it was fantastic I appreciate
you guys for coming out cannot wait to
do this again as things get heated maybe
the next time we do this is a win uh our
our guy from Florida announces that he's
running we'll be here we'll both be here
maybe we'll come out and do a live event
at our Cigar Lounge and our club right
next door and we'll have a live audience
of two or three hundred people and we'll
do that with them and uh make it a
difference
I really appreciate it thank you Rob if
we can put the link below to any book
that he would the book he was talking
about if there is a link to it not up
yet it's going to be out at August 8th
I'm not even supposed to talk about it
yet because we haven't officially I
think April 17th the link will go up but
what you're pitching as a marketer
you're gonna see this and you're gonna
be like I I guarantee you're gonna love
it but but put up the clan Buck podcast
please that link that's up now that will
happen we'll have that at both places go
down there subscribe listen to these
folks not that they need more listeners
but you got to hear what these guys have
to say take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye